JEREMY WALKER: Hi, my
name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
Welcome back to our
series on the Three
Flaws of Software Design
with Max Kanat-Alexander.
This is on the third
flaw, so why don't we
just jump right into it?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
So this is the third of our
Three Flaws of Software Design.
And this third one
is, being too generic.
Often, this is called
over-engineering.
It's an attempt to accommodate
every future requirement now
even though you
can't actually know
all the future requirements now.
This is a flaw that senior
developers frequently
fall into.
So junior developers often
fall into our previous flaw,
which is writing code
that is too rigid
or that doesn't
have enough design.
But senior developers
have done that,
and they've been bitten by it.
They've been bitten by change.
And they want to
try to accommodate
every possible change now.
And this sounds a little
bit like our first flaw,
which was writing code
that you don't need.
And it's sort of a
specialized case of that.
But there's a little bit
more to know about it,
so I pulled it out
as its own flaw.
The problem that it
has is that you've
put in a ton of effort
for very little value.
Basically, like when you've
design something that's
very, very generic, you're
not delivering the value
of the code that you
wrote to the user.
The amount of work you did,
and the amount of value
that the user actually
gets out of it,
are not proportional
to each other.
Because you've
done a lot of work
that doesn't actually deliver
any value to the user.
Now, sometimes that's
OK, because you're
doing good design.
But over-engineering,
or being too generic,
trying to meet requirements,
future requirements,
that you don't know about
yet is not good design.
Developers do this all the
time by trying to be good.
They've been taught
certain practices,
and they want to
follow these practices.
But they don't
understand that there's
certain times when you don't
need to follow those practices.
People want to catch
every exception,
but there are some
exceptions that
don't need to be caught that you
really should just let bubble
up to the surface, because
otherwise you're hiding errors.
And it actually makes it
harder to debug the system.
When you try to handle
input that you never
get-- when we did our code
review for the first flaw,
you saw some of that.
Handling situations
you're never in,
like trying to make
thread safe code that
doesn't need to be thread
safe-- I've done this.
It's a nightmare.
You're adding locks
everywhere, and it really
just adds a week of
work to a project
that should have taken a day.
Or dependency injection,
when there's only one choice
that there could ever
be-- this is probably
most common in the Java world,
because dependency injection
is very popular.
And I'm not saying that
dependency injection is bad.
But I'm saying that
dependency injection when
you don't need it is bad.
You shouldn't be doing
speculative dependency
injection, basically.
Like, you shouldn't be guessing,
oh, well, in the future,
we might need to do
dependency injection,
so I should just do it now.
In general, these can all
be summed up as, one day,
we might need to do foo
so I should do foo now.
Let's give an example.
So let's say that I want to
write an HTTP server that
communicates over a TCP socket.
And I have a bunch
of time on my hands.
And I think that I am the
world's best developer,
and I just want to do an
awesome, awesome job on this.
So what I do is, I'm
going to be, like, OK,
I'm going to really, really
design this, super design this,
but I'm going to
over-engineer it.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to have multiple--
you know, there might
be other types of sockets, other
than TCP sockets in the future.
So we have a socket,
and a socket type,
and a socket factory
to make our sockets,
and then have a TCP socket.
So by the way, any
time you see a factory
they can only produce
one object, that
is something to be suspect of.
Or we want to say,
oh, but maybe we'll
support other protocols,
other than HTTP.
So we should have an abstract
request class, and then
a type for the request, and then
a request factory, and an HTTP
request, and the same
thing for the responses.
And then, that means
also that the request
has to understand the
response it creates
and the socket type
that it came in on.
So there's going to be all this
complexity in implementing,
sort of, generic socket
handling and generic request
handling in your
generic response,
and also in your
generic request.
And then, you know
what, everybody
likes configuration files.
So instead of writing code to
make our HTTP server behave
a different way, let's
write configuration files,
not because we need
them, just because we
think we might need
them in the future.
And specifically, let's
make it so that the sockets
can configure themselves.
Because we want to have
different configurations
of sockets.
I don't know why.
But, you know, you
just want to configure
them to have different
time outs, or something.
And so, we need to be able to
read socket types from files,
basically, not like a
serialization format,
but just a configuration.
And you know, because
we like being efficient,
in production, we want
to have a binary version
for this configuration,
but binary configurations
are hard to debug.
So in development,
we want to have
a text version of this
configuration file.
And then, in
production, we probably
want to store this configuration
file in a database,
but in development,
we might want
to store it in the file system.
So we should have different
ways to store this HTTP server.
So, what's wrong
with this picture?
It required 15 classes.
And HTTP is a complex protocol
to implement, particularly
if you also have to implement
a lot of TCP underneath it.
So I would say that
all that complexity
is going to make it take
one person-year to do this
and maybe 30,000 lines of code.
And also, you're going
to have to write way,
way more tests
than you would have
to, otherwise,
because you're going
to have all these generic
situations that you have
to make sure are actually valid.
But, let's say that we
did this more simply.
What's the non-generic
implementation?
The non-generic implementation
is three classes--
socket, request, and response.
How long is that going to take?
I don't know, maybe two to three
person-months, maybe even less
if you don't implement
the entire HTTP spec.
And the reason it's
going to take that long
is because HTTP is genuinely
a complex thing to implement.
But the work you'll
be doing is all work
that actually delivers
value to the user.
Those two to three months
are all valuable time
spent working, as opposed to the
other eight or nine months that
would have been spent
making this thing generic,
which, ultimately, the
product is identical.
The product that you're
delivering is identical.
I'm not encouraging
bad design and saying
you should hack
things out quickly.
What I'm saying is, I'm
discouraging over-design.
And the rule that you can
apply to get out of this flaw,
to resolve this flaw,
is be only as generic
as you need to be right now.
And how generic is that?
Well, you need to
be generic enough so
that you never duplicate code,
so that your design is simple,
and so that your
system is stable.
So my rule for duplication
is that two is too many.
Once I want to basically copy
and paste a piece of code,
ever, even once, then
I start to think, OK,
how can I have a super class?
Or how can I have
a utility function,
or something like that?
You want to keep it simple,
so that it's understandable.
So sometimes you want
to abstract things
out of the classes,
because otherwise it
would be very difficult
to understand the code.
Or you want to abstract
thing out of the functions,
because it makes it easier
to understand the code.
And you want the
system to be stable.
So sometimes there's
a certain amount
of complexity in handling
error conditions,
and you need to handle
those error conditions,
even if you haven't seen
them already in production.
The fact that somebody
sends you a bad HTTP request
should not be a
security vulnerability.
So you might have
to handle that.
And that sort of wraps
it up for our third flaw.
Any questions?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, so again,
just like the other videos,
you had a great
example in the book--
I think it was related
to email-- that I
was hoping you would cover.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Sure, so this
was actually another
Bugzilla example.
So what we wanted to do was
every time that you change
a bug, Bugzilla sends
out a bunch of emails.
And this is very
slow, because Bugzilla
used to do it synchronously.
It would actually update
the bug, then send an email.
And if you were updating a
bunch of bugs all at once,
it would update the first
bug, send the first email,
update the next bug,
send the next email,
send the next email.
And email sending is
actually very slow.
Like talking to Send
Mail, and actually getting
it to acknowledge that
the email has been queued,
actually, it can take
a couple seconds.
So if you were
changing 1,000 bugs,
literally, people would
just open a browser tab
and leave it there all day.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, wow.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
And so, one of our big
feature requests was,
can we do this asynchronously?
And so we found a little
demon that could do it for us,
a little queuing demon,
that could do it for us.
And it could store little
blobs in the database
that you could read back
out and send an email.
So basically, there was
an asynchronous demon
that sat alongside and would
just pull all the database
for emails that
needed to be sent.
And we had this all spec'd out.
And then, the developer
who actually came around
to implement it said,
well, maybe people
are going to want to use
some other queuing system.
Maybe they have their
own queuing system.
And they don't want to
use our queuing system.
So he made the whole thing able
to have plug-ins, basically,
to have plug-ins for other
queue management systems, other
than the queue management
system that we had chosen.
And even in the code
review, I was like,
I can't understand this code.
I can't understand this change.
I can't review this change.
And eventually, he got
called off to do other work,
and another developer
took it over.
And that developer ripped
out all of the generic bits
and the change became 100
lines of code or less, maybe
like 75 lines of
code, to implement
this super-critical feature.
And I immediately
approved it, basically.
I was like, this is really easy.
It's going to go in.
And the fact of the matter
is that in the three years
after that that I worked
on the Bugzilla project,
nobody ever requested to
use another queuing system.
And if they had,
they were probably
bright enough developers to
write custom code themselves,
because this was an
open source project.
So it ultimately ended
up not being necessary
and way, way simpler just
to have non-generic code.
JEREMY WALKER: Wow, great.
Well, that covers our
third flaw in the series.
We have one more
video, where we're
going to talk a little bit more
about some stuff and some wrap
up materials.
So make sure you
tune in for that.
Thank you.